today's episode is brought to you by
gray block pizza gray block it's that
pizza that you need first off I want to
let you know that next weekend I will be
at Irvine improv in Irvine California
January 18th through the 20th so come on
out and get that action
today's guest he started off as a
YouTube content creator when he was in
college and then he really escalated
into some different style activities as
the star of American vandal season 1
he's now in films he was in 22 Jump
Street he's doing all types of precious
activities and also he was gonna say and
also that's it ladies and gentlemen mr.
Jimmy Tatro
[Music]
and I've never met you before man but we
have a mutual friend dan McGann we do I
was just texting and actually were you
yeah he was like he was like talking
about you to me he was like I feel like
you'd get along with my buddy Theo man
oh that's nice I mean yeah and I was
like wait I think I never look right
when I had just gotten like the the
podcast thing through my inbox and I was
like oh I think I just got fed up about
his podcast oh that's perfect yeah
perfect timing
yeah our Booker actually is uh it's in a
new movie did you tell you about that in
the hallway no I didn't Oh movie with
Octavia Spencer coming out who's our
Booker is Gianni
no no I was like we need Jimmy on yeah
yeah so but for now he's our Booker and
he's unpaid now that's where we're at
with him you know you know obviously we
don't let his agent interfere on how we
handle business with them you know
because we probably have to pay more but
know you know yeah Gianni helped us have
you and we're happy to have you man nice
yeah well happy to be here
yeah but yeah dan is a wild guy so dan
was one of the producers for a vandal
yeah yeah he was a showrunner yeah and
he uh at first I was I was like who is
this guy yeah super you know he was like
talking about everything on such a deep
level about yeah I was like and then I
started to really like get to know him
and I was like how this guy knows what's
up
yeah he's good he's good yeah he kind of
looks like a strongest [ __ ]
nine-year-old ever you know mom takes
care of like a like a nine-year-old that
was taken care of by his mother you know
like has a lunch you know like that guy
you know this sandwich is cut in a force
you know like he already knows in the
morning what kind of like flavor of
beverage he's gonna have at school you
know I never had like that
love care put into my lunches really
like I mean it's not like my parents
didn't care they did their best you know
right but like I was never getting like
these big elaborate turkey sandwiches
like a little item or something it was
like a PB&J yeah that's maybe some chips
or just Jay one time I just got a whole
bunch of Jay yeah I've never heard of
just Jay usually would be just PB oh
yeah if you're out you and I got in D
for a while in the elementary school his
PB and honey oh yeah that was great
cuz the honey kind of like makes a
little bit of the bread kind of hard
right it just kind of really coagulates
in there it was and it was like a nice
switch up when you got too used to the
PB&J yeah like we got to [ __ ] change
our lives yeah dude I remember speaking
of college I remember eating some
mushrooms one yeah and and of having
things to eat I ate some mushrooms one
time I got so excited cuz I met this
girl that's kind of not you know I think
she was a white or maybe Spanish or
something but she was about five seven
and so I met her and I was excited I was
on mushrooms at this party I got her
phone number bro this is a girl who in
my imagination would never talk to me
like I'd imagined thousands of ways that
I approached her in every imagine it or
e time it didn't end well for me yeah
like at one time I was even on a ship
and she was like you know kidnapped and
stuff and still no yeah it was like hey
I'll get you out here and she's like
I'll just stay with the kidnappers so
every experience I even had you know
hypothetically hadn't gone well I got
her number and I was like man I'm [ __ ]
living on large you know I'm one of
God's favorites right now and I just got
beeline ran out of this party over they
had a fence like a chain-link fence and
I thought I'm like I'm gonna prove to
this girl I'm a [ __ ] man right she
don't even know why I'm doing this I'm
just just beeline right for this
chain-link fence probably bout five feet
and try to just jump over it like
stomach first right my hand got caught
on the chain-link ripped my hand open so
now my hands open I'm bleeding never
where everybody's alarmed I don't know
what happened to her but anyway so my
friends like we need to go to the
hospital and one of my friends is like
well dude here's what you can do to
better take care of yourself cuz you're
bleeding
everywhere put your mouth over the cut
and suck and keep the blood in your body
right swallow the blood yeah so yeah I
had the mouth I had my hand over the cut
and I was basically just sucking like I
was like my arm was a straw and I could
feel it yeah I could feel more blood
coming from my heart like I'm just
drinking it just going yeah just like
this yeah so yeah we need to talk about
eating you know kind of wild stuff in
college or something like that or having
a wife yeah but that was a tough time
for me that time but where'd you go to
college I went to Louisiana State okay
yeah and you went to USC went to school
out here no I went to University of
Arizona oh you did mm-hmm
bear down bro I'm on kolben Pantano dude
Wow
yeah I went there for one year nice yeah
okay it was pretty good there was not
ASU that's what I thought of it is oh
really i fund me and I [ __ ] hate it
yes you did now why cuz they were what
the rich kids fancy no I think they were
definitely less fancy than you were
there they just were they were the bad
guys in that rivalry yeah they were all
rivals there the Sun Devils yeah so you
already know who the bad guys are yeah
there's like a hundred thousand kids
there oh yeah we were like visiting
there all the time and nobody cares even
it's like a town issue is like a like a
not even a small town like a hundred
thousand people that's a decent sized
City they got the tits they got the coke
up there I mean it's definitely the
cocaine built you know yeah runs right
through kind of Scottsdale but now you
of a dude I remember it's a good place
to get like a couple of you know magical
crystals you know it's a good place to
get some turquoise you know I saw a
school bus there one time somebody
completely cut the top of it off and was
just driving it well yeah that's some
Tucson stuff yeah that's totally Tucson
you know if your song is a wild place
yeah what is it it's just the armpit of
America that's what they call it yeah
but it's like the armpit is braided and
has some [ __ ] turquoise barrette
right some be you know man yeah the
armpit has a dreamcatcher hanging a lot
of dream catchers in there you know so
do you really struck
big out here in Hollywood um yeah I mean
sure I'm trying doing right asked yeah
and does it feel like was there a moment
your life when he started to realize
like what it was like to just be like a
popularity was like oh this is getting
to another level and how quickly it
escalated yeah well there was like in
college that was like the peak of my
fame like I was like when I was making
videos about college in college Wow
that was when it was like like I don't
experience that kind of stuff now
obviously because we're in LA and no one
gives a [ __ ] out now that yeah which is
which is honestly cool because like
that's not fun yeah but like you know
when I would go to like island I was
shouldn't movie in New Orleans and Liv
Jump Street
yeah Jump Street yeah and it was when
LSU played Florida oh yeah everyone was
on Bourbon and I just remember like I
just was straight up getting mobbed like
I remember like standing on Bourbon and
like one person was like oh my god let
me get a photo and then like the second
the flash went off they were like all of
a sudden there was like like 40 kids
yeah and I like couldn't escape like I
was like like running yeah I was like I
felt like I was like Justin Bieber or
some [ __ ] yeah and that was I mean that
was like a one-time like that was just
the craziest it's ever been or Justin
boots you ever seen those boots no what
are they popular in the south to you
could be either one of those characters
yeah I love it yeah Justin boots it's
like nice boots do you think when okay
so you had that experience right so I'll
tell you this um phousi ever since I got
fuzzy on YouTube yeah so anyway I met
this guy one time and I honestly I
thought he was a real [ __ ] clown [ __ ]
he just had a really intense ego that's
what I felt like about the young guy and
I think he got he fraudulently made some
videos that were like you know watch
this butterfly hug this homeless guy you
know yeah I mean you know see what
happens when this seven when the seven
month old baby crawls past his homeless
guy you know like that those kind of
videos always he did those like you know
videos that kind of fed into that whole
clique baby thing yeah and it was fake
was like it was prearranged it was like
a thumbnail like this yeah it looks like
I can't believe she said that yeah you
know it's like guess who gets leprosy
and it's just like yeah yeah it's a guy
like a blanket yeah so yeah definitely
like some wild stuff but romanette was a
buddy of mine too right he's great and
Roman is great he's like you know he's
super you know him and Dennis Roady
super cool cats but the most famous een
somebody have from a fan perspective was
seeing it was fuzzy outside of the
parking lot and The Improv we shot
something one time and it was just I'd
never seen anything like it it was like
four hundred kids all the phone's going
like in a mob like literally she was
unbelievable he like let people know he
was there he must have he must have said
you know I'm shooting something here
I'll come outside and say hey or
something yeah yeah so it's prearranged
because like a lot of people do that
like I used to see like you know DJ
Khaled was all about that for a while
like I'm gonna be it like you've gotta
have a meeting at this place through to
my meeting I'm like if I was meeting up
with DJ Khaled in like all of a sudden
there's a thousand people outside I'd be
like maybe don't tweet out our address
yeah yeah I'm gonna bun you shaved off
22nd a service one like you do that and
it makes you look way more famous than
you are right where it's like if that
actually happened and you know like like
when someone like Bieber like One
Direction is like staying at a hotel
yeah like you ever like drive by it's
like a hotel on Sunset and just see like
a mob of people outside yeah and you're
like how do they like one person found
out and like let everyone know like all
the fan accounts well probably
understand here's message boards and
it's always like yeah somebody's outside
their hairs died like green and brown
they all have green in all the hair
colors man I used to go to VidCon mm-hmm
no normal colored hair and what is
VidCon so tell me about what that is
VidCon is my honest VidCon is like
comic-con
for screening twelve-year-old girls who
are fans of YouTube channel okay so now
would you have like grace Helbig and
people like that there is well romanette
well that would would kill it at VidCon
right Lucy would kill it at VidCon
essence you are the UH Dudesons yeah
Djuka Doutzen dukkha Doutzen Dudesons
yes I've heard of the device there's
slot there's Slovenian but there or
there something out another from [ __ ]
somewhere but it's like a massive
convention in Anaheim okay you're
walking around and I mean you for the
most part have no idea who any of these
people are besides like you know there's
like very few people on YouTube that are
like in my same like age group slash
people I would hang on this last style
yeah yeah it's maybe that one dude that
supposed to fight CM Punk who is that
guy Logan wasn't looking Paul yeah Logan
Paul mmm-hmm it would I be you're older
than him probably a little bit a little
bit right a little bit yeah
yeah and yeah it seems like that's more
his life in your life is differently
well you know you're just walking around
and you just all of a sudden you'll hear
like like we go here waves of scream
yeah I mean they'll be like oh that's so
and so yeah that's snuffie Johansson I
couldn't go to the you makes a snail
sweaters and I started getting big lead
by like jiff palm no you know jiff palm
uh-uh
is it an animal yeah it's a little fuzzy
I'm really Pomeranian dog hmm
who's just a star at these things and
what's it what's gifs skillset I mean
Jill gif actually has some skills really
you know I would like as much as I would
like to sit here and you can like walk
on his hand
that's cool yeah dude I know a [ __ ]
uh yeah I know a couple of dogs that
have [ __ ] that little thing yeah no
dude you could probably hire a wolf to
[ __ ] sneak in there and eat little
jiff brother who died anything at first
dude I know a guy could probably [ __ ] a
snack on that little bastard how big is
it he's like this big I mean don't get
me wrong he's
he's super cute he's a cute little fuzzy
dog but you know I was on a red carpet
one time and the guy said they said hey
that guy's gonna interview go over there
and I walk over to him and I'm like just
standing there the guy's like not really
like looking at me he's like looking
like passed me and I'm like standing
there like okay they told me to like
come get interviewed by this guy
anything hey down so sorry we're
actually um gonna interview Jeff right
now so um Wow I'm like so yeah I didn't
ask for this
yeah way to come over here and now I'm
getting big league by a little ball that
was rough man that was a tough well the
good thing is Jeff's only gonna live
probably most eight more six more years
and you know to be honest but dude yeah
that's gotta be baffling now do you is
there a little bit of ego in that were
you like [ __ ] this is [ __ ] I mean
you never want to feel like that guys
like I don't like those things anyways
and it's like I don't like want to get
caught up and all that but when someone
tells you go over there get rid of you
and you're like I'm it's gonna go with
the flow and then you get over there and
then the guys like ooh actually man as
if I asked to get anything right no I
hate that yeah ask to be your [ __ ]
putting in a position where like I'm
getting flexed on by a little Pomeranian
yeah under view a dog anyways what do
they do
this then oh well he has that ball and
they're showing a picture right now jiff
gots a football and that's Jeff all
things dog blog you see the picture
above seems walking on his hands it's
not this isn't one of those Chinese dogs
that they give it the pills and its
tongue hangs out of his mouth is it you
say give those things pills yeah there's
a big bunch of stuff now but we looked
at up Chinese dopin cute animals or
something I don't know what you would
but yeah they're giving him pills that's
why you know they're all just tongue out
of there I was just the type of dog you
just like was just been drinking all day
[Laughter]
no but the Chinese have been do
a lot of that a thing and I also get you
know who knows it with this what do you
see a Nick I have known anything about
the controversy but here's a marketing
type did Manny the dog ever weird sorry
how I know that but yeah yeah I don't
want to know you know Manny the dog I
mean now that I'm looking at him they
definitely look like they could be
drugged oh do you see a Bichon on a
couple of quaaludes bro no the game has
changed for these animals it's not the
same as it used to be but you know
they're born into this family didn't ask
for it what else I was gonna ask you
about so so that was the type of fame
that YouTube fame there was nothing like
that in a win in a unique way
yeah I mean I think that was just like a
unique time when like I was I mean I it
was knowledge YouTube is all timing you
know so like at the time I was like one
of the only people that was really doing
sketch comedy and no one was really
doing like college sketch comedy except
for maybe college humor but like but at
that point college humor had become like
more like adult humor anyway yeah so
like I don't know it was it was just
videos that like when I was the college
guy right and then that night on Bourbon
Street was like the biggest
concentration of like every fan I'd had
Wow was like those southern frat guys
from LSU and Florida State and they were
all in one place and I was there and
then once it was like someone shined a
light it was like there he is like a
roach like a beautiful rug yeah but like
that's not you know normal for me yeah
ya know that's you know it's funny man
is it makes me think like whenever I was
um you know when I before I even got
into Hollywood I got in a stand-up I did
a reality show right I was a road rules
cast of a show called Road rules it was
a show we're gonna travel around and
play games you know yeah and this was
when they only had 32 television
channels right I mean MTV was that it's
it was at its height like we the show
got like 14 million views watches a week
which now would be something you'd see
on
and network like a you know like walking
dead numbers right so those are huge
numbers but this is yeah and so I had an
experience one night on Bourbon Street
and I was there and it was um
and it was I was in college around that
time so it was basically like you know
you go to any college town or any
college bar and it was just you were
this you were really for me at that time
I was more like you were a connection to
MTV in a way for people like that's what
I feel like they kind of thought like
this is like a human embodiment of that
channel because MTV was huge then like
it was it was the it was our YouTube it
was everything all in one one channel
you know it was like YouTube teams he
was all in one little space you know but
I had a crazy experience one night like
that
oh dude so one night and Louisiana a lot
of dudes would be [ __ ] to this one
of the reasons why I ended up leaving um
LSU is because a lot of kids would be
[ __ ] just rude like kids always
trying to fight like at the bars as beer
bottles whizzing by my head just you
know I don't know jealous or angry
ignorance they just want to like and I
know you'll know what I'm talking about
it's like they just they don't want you
to think that they like you right but
they want to say something
yeah they don't know really how I say it
or what they want to say they just want
to like let you know that they know who
you are yes but not that they like you
right but I know what's going on yeah
yeah you're that guy yeah but don't
[ __ ] I'm good I mean I don't [ __ ]
care yeah yeah man look what I've my boy
has yeah I just said that you were maybe
yeah but that's such a big I know
exactly and then at a certain point when
you walk in a room you can tell already
where people know you start to get that
feeling okay those two guys already
pointing me out that person isn't this
these are the [ __ ] pitfalls they're
gonna swing over they're gonna flank me
from the left for a photo in about 19
seconds but isn't it weird how that all
becomes a little bit of a microcosm in
some of those spaces ya know it really
does it's such a weird thing to like
that whole what I don't know just the
way that you get approached like a girl
came out to man talents like like all
like [ __ ] and
99 likes making YouTube videos yeah I'm
like well yeah and you're like okay look
at me like are you gonna make me like
you that kind of a look and I was just
like I just didn't say any of like yeah
and then she walked away like what a
dick what was I supposed to do there
yeah I had no good
that's what I used to keep a little bit
of birdseed for [ __ ] like that you
know I'm like this girl is nothing but a
little pigeon you know yeah I say you
come get a little bit of this [ __ ]
birds no I'll leave a little bit of seed
on there so very but yeah you'd have all
kind of yeah like uh I don't even know I
guess I'm supposed to get a picture with
you people say that kind of [ __ ] hey can
I have a picture like my friend one my
friend yeah can I just like have a
picture like [ __ ] friend yeah it's
always a friend yeah and it's like well
you seem like a [ __ ] you don't even
like your friend like what you don't
like me yeah yeah what do you do but it
is interesting cause you start to pick
on it some up on some people social
skills and what some of their social
skills are like yeah but when I was at
LSU like so one night I was at a bar at
Tulane over there in New Orleans right
and so we're bar that one bar that's
right on campus yes the boot yeah I was
at the boot dude and I had [ __ ] wet
socks I remember because this what
happened is that I'm like a metaphor for
something well wet socks is a racial
slur in some areas it is Johnny why
don't you left like a regular person huh
laughs huh
no no one does do laugh like a
seven-year-old businessman you know you
actually have like a white guy that has
definitely been taken advantage of our
country but yeah some kids chased me
into a house brother like [ __ ] this dude
they chased me and I run up on the first
porch I see not gonna do work oh it's a
girl in there I was like these people
chased me Kenny and she's like yeah as I
call it's a college kid and so next you
know I'm in their place there's like
people are passed out everywhere these
dudes are running around the house
start throwing bricks through the
windows bro
bricks bricks bro or big rocks I mean I
don't know where they got who that's
just full-on dangerous oh it was crazy
it was like a time to kill you know
every room I go into another brick the
thighs in and I literally went through
the house and then ran right out and
like no joke probably three or four
windows were [ __ ] broken in this
lady's house no clue who I was from this
girl's perspective she's just like still
loose about is still sitting at the
dining room table like eating a bowl of
cereal like what the [ __ ] just happened
like Stephanie I told you not to answer
the [ __ ] bill all college girls are
just calling their dad about insurance
claims I feel like most right there's a
lot of like drunk calls to dads that
happen oh I've witnessed that's all I
can't even imagine yeah like dad check
my phone one morning it was like
Lindsay's dad was it um and was it easy
to I mean obviously was easy to meet
chicks was it scary to meet chicks at
that time when you were in that College
in the end you know cuz you've had an
interesting interesting career so far
because you've had you've got no
experience different types of fame and
popularity mm-hmm not to G not and nots
you know like trying to blow your ego
well but it's just it's interesting a
lot of people don't get to experience
different genres of that know what
that's like
yeah ya know it was a I mean it was it
was fun in college like I like he had a
good time it was yeah I had a great time
in college I like got like towards the
end that was just like really I got kind
of paranoid on campus like I just like
felt like I was felt like there was
always eyes and you're looking I just
like I had this the loudest [ __ ] Dodge
Challenger and like Oh like I got I
started hating driving it like through
campus
second I pull up everyone like tantrum I
call a challenger like driving around
all ashamed in this Challenger that I
thought was sick when I first bought it
and the Challenger exploded who would
even name a car after that didn't the
Challenger explode really you know that
yeah I was like a NASA shuttle probably
right around the time you were born that
[ __ ] blew up killed a couple school
teachers I think and I think that a dog
and a brother on that thing even who was
can you pull up the crew let's see yeah
that thing blew up winter blow up can
you let me know the date it was mm-hmm
when you're born in 90 92 damn commanded
by Francis Kobe can we get a picture
let's click on my picture man down there
down so that's not an actual Dodge
Challenger that's a spaceship it's nice
out on all those people died the puppy's
not there oh well hopefully it was yum
yum what's that guy's name that puppy
that [ __ ] chief palm Jeff on yeah yum
yum dude I'll [ __ ] Jeff palm bruh that
little [ __ ] yeah man
I'll say this bring it Jeff ok hey Jeff
I would like to say it right now I've
beef with Jim well wouldn't that be such
a great doggy treat you guys come out
with partner up I got beef with the Jeff
palm I can smell a collab coming yeah
and this is it you never seen this no
I've seen this this is the very tragic
this morning though they were not going
to be able to get off they didn't know
what happened did like without a live
announce you're talking about it yeah
you didn't react I don't think they
don't what's going
okay cuz like if I'm watching this yeah
like that didn't sound like what the why
the other Brian oh my god Oh No
he's like still talking about yeah
they're approaching someone so not a
home ions it's like no they're not
well let's redo it go back a little bit
and we'll be the newscasters you mean
all right we heard Stennis Space Center
here I got a mom Florida a very exciting
day for all of us here at CNN getting to
witness the Challenger now launch of a
challenge and is really getting up there
nothing yeah I think what about some
60,000 nautical miles not a mile a lot
of nautical miles right over there near
Coral Gables us passing over this
stadium right under them now these
spaceships the new ones are actually
built with this new material that makes
them so much more durable oh gosh so
much safer mm-hmm and you know looks
safe to me boom I know Jehovah that is
is this going in a couple directions now
I don't think that was I don't think
that's what was supposed to happen oh
it's coming back it seems like maybe
there no that's exactly what's supposed
to happen kids this is what's supposed
to happen they're coming back a
challenger there they are there's
somebody that's crazy man oh yeah I
remember we were in class and they
wheeled in a television and people
watched and didn't saw that live kids
were all watching and everybody was
excited it was like a big day in America
oh man hey well rest in peace to that
all those people on the Challenger huh
Thank You Bernie thank you for risking
your lives it was the first time I saw
two women up there
some people said it's because the women
got in a fight in the shuttle uh and
that's why I blew up but that's just a
rumor
dude now were you you of a did you take
any astronomy classes I did dude so did
I I did and I was like the only thing I
liked and we got a telescope bro they
had so much [ __ ] nightlife in the air
oh man that that like the airport what's
it called like then light pollution yeah
no animal no stars
yeah isn't like some [ __ ] has a
nightlight a couple blocks over and
that's it
there was this we had the it was a stars
class I was in I forget things was it a
man that taught her yeah yeah it was
like this NASA guy who like Brody moto x
bikes and [ __ ] and like thought he was
so sick he was like showed us a
slideshow on day one and he was like
this is me on my dirt bike
how old was it he was like 40 years
something I don't know if I could have
been the same guy or not probably not
was it intro astronomy course it was
like I was a freshman when I took it
yeah me too I got kicked out of that
class a few times for he pointed me out
one time I was asleep in like the second
row yeah and oh yeah and it's so weird
waking up into a situation where
everyone's looking at you yeah cuz I was
asleep in like the second row and
apparently he was like look at this guy
just sleeping in the second row probably
hungover I had like out like a wrist
band on from my hands before you think
probably look at his wrist band probably
hungover right now and like he's like
why don't you get your buddy up to my
friend nudges me and I just like wake up
and I just oh he's awake and just a
classroom of a thousand people starts
laughing and I'm just like now you can't
go back to sleep that's the worst part
yeah I might go back to sleep that
actually be pretty legendary if I can
work on Google what um so now you have
you are are you working in films now
what's that been like cuz you moved on I
mean you just kind of gone right at the
scale yeah I mean I I still like I don't
know like I still would like to make
youtube videos it's just not a very uh
[Music]
good idea from you know I'm right it
isn't as well yeah business-wise like
it's just like I could spend the money
to shoot a sketch
yeah and upload it to YouTube and make
no money on it yeah
or I could like save those ideas and
like profit off of them yeah excited to
be seen in a movie yes is something that
like is bigger I still I want to put
stuff on YouTube it's just like I don't
know the platform just is not for
sketches right now right it's for gamers
it's for beauty tutorials it's for vlogs
it's for like stuff that doesn't cost
any money to shoot yeah and like crap
sure yeah I'm not gonna disagree with
that only like a couple people on
YouTube that I think do good stuff and
there's more value to you I'm guessing
as artists these days as on bigger
screens you know you started off on the
small screen like the smallest screen
possible yeah yeah you know well
Facebook is still technically a small
screen that's true I had that that's
what I've been working on for like the
last few months is real boroughs of Simi
Valley and that's for Facebook watch
yeah yeah and that's been a lot of fun
I just finished episode 10 yesterday
other boroughs real no no I mean I'm one
of them yeah you know so and what does
it feed is it feel like you guys are
real it does it does it's uh like you
know parody reality show oh yeah yeah so
it's like if you'd like it yeah yeah is
it like the UM well tell me what it's
like so it's just basically I think the
description of the show that's on
Facebook is living and see me has always
been pretty chill for these four best
friends but now that they just graduated
from high school ten years ago it's time
to move on Kean - um oh this is a
trailer do you want it yeah let's watch
it so we can
I'm pregnant what do you mean prices
skating again baby calm down
I just got into Community College of
Moorpark school and photography oh so
sick
loke sucks not being able to get faith
because I got a son right now
dorm life was good finally out of Simi
Valley I just can't wait to start this
new chapter in my life
yes outlook yeah it's still being back
in the board it's starting to forget how
much STIs actually have good if you win
this you could shred full-time 500 bucks
how much weight is that okay Molly and I
might be leading seen it just like
Javier's everybody I mean right so it's
all like too thick it's totally fiction
was based up exactly how we act it's
like the most it's just like you know
these reality shows like nothing [ __ ]
happened oh yeah they just edit it to
make it look like stuff happens they
just put these crazy music and all these
sound OH Samantha's tits leaking you
know yeah guess she can't come to dinner
so it's like the original idea was like
you just make a show like that just
shows it's like [ __ ] nothing happens
but we just have all this crazy music
and sound hype it up like something
happens but season 2 like a lot of [ __ ]
is happening it's ten episodes now
they're all like 15 minutes and is there
is it like abortions or what are the
kids doing on the weekends a skate is so
is there like a modern so one guy my
character just had a kid so he's like
dealing with that [ __ ] and he works at a
body shop one of the best friends and my
born year old have beef right now so he
keeps trying to fight this kid yeah one
of the other guys just started college
school of photography oh so he's over
there working now yeah it's like that's
like an Instagram
nowadays if you're doing a college class
that's an app then you're [ __ ] well
you know so he's uh and then the other
guy works at he used to work at his
dad's surf shop but then he got dumped
by his fiancee because she wanted more
so he decided to quit his job and now
he's trying to figure out something new
right what's he gonna do CBD oil no he's
actually starting a surf shop without
his dad yeah but what we're doing
actually that's pretty cool is uh like
all the characters have Instagram
accounts and so they're all posting as
if they're real people like in line with
what's going on in the show really so
like you know Duncan gets dumped in
Episode one and the following week it's
all like sad photos of him like
third-wheeling and you're like one like
actually feeling so great and happy
lately that's great like a meet like you
know like a inspirational quo yeah and
then the other guys like and then they
all comment on each other's stuff oh
that's crazy so it's not another world
yeah like breaking the photo with my kid
the guy who like hates my kid will
comment like an eye rolling emoji yeah
[ __ ] Bronson what's the kid's name hawk
so it's just like all these it's about
the like big valley lifted truck like Oh
cliched wearing bras yeah it's bro
tastic yeah it's wrote esque pretty
funny yeah that's cool man no I love
this head just shows like the parody
type of shows they had one on this is on
Yahoo for a while but it was about the
burning love yes
yeah that was really good yeah it
reminds me of that a little bit but just
more like youthful yeah it was like too
right yeah I mean what like what was
cool about vandal is like it was it felt
so real
and like I kind of wanted to take a
little bit of that real feeling and like
just like in terms of like the camera
styles in the way we shot it like I
wanted to feel like a real reality show
right so if people think it's real then
it's like nice do you think there's some
people who think it is real I don't know
cuz it's so [ __ ] ridiculous that it's
like like there's literally an
ongoing beef between like us 27 year old
and a one year old child is getting held
back from fighting a kid that he like it
wanna be like like the kid doesn't say
anything like what'd you say and he's
like sounds like you're talking [ __ ] and
someone who's talking [ __ ] like you
deserves to get locked in a hot car with
the windows rolled up it was like whoa
dude wow I don't know how you can watch
something like that and think it's real
yeah but at the same time like people
thought vandal was real people think
things are real man people thought this
video I did with like a make-a-wish
Foundation kid was real hmm where it's
like a kid running for a touchdown and
then an out of nowhere like someone
comes and tackles the [ __ ] out of him
he's grilled out yeah people thought
that was real and it's like in the first
five seconds of the video
the announcers like Tommy Douglas born
with a potato for a heart he's gonna
undergo a heart transplant surgery but
we're gonna have him run the first
touchdown you know says he gets born
four with a potato for a heart yeah you
know and Michael Irvin you know football
legend tweeted the video out like oh I
feel so bad for laughing but life isn't
just messed up I'm like dude you think
it's so some people think it's real yeah
like Michael Irvin yeah Michael Irvin is
a flat earther and also flattered with
nothing started in the black community
years ago all my black friends were like
bro bro no school bro flat earthers made
a big push getting its led by b.o.b the
rapper really I think you still on his
Twitter he's always I don't see a curve
like skylines like no curve Kyrie
Irving's huge on that stuff to you he
was I think he's had since renounced his
Flat Earth beliefs probably just people
quieting him I bet he yeah dude shut you
got to stop
because it's growing on one of our
busiest episodes that we've ever had was
we had a guy named Eddie Bravo and he is
big into he started like 10th planet
jiu-jitsu and he was like a he's like a
jiu-jitsu fighter and now like a like a
like what he's you know he's liaison to
the uncertain elements of the universe
he's like a Sherpa down the [ __ ]
stairs steps into hell and possibility
and uh and but he I was at I was in
Louisiana called weeks ago our breakfast
and some waitress comes up and just sits
down right next to me she's like oh my
god tell me everything about Eddie Brock
you know like people are into that whole
stuff now like it's getting deeper you
know like I met Buzz Aldrin the man that
been to the moon yeah well that's right
chef when I looked him in the eyes bro
no joke I didn't get the feeling that he
had that person I'm looking at it been
there really no I'm saying like if you
told me like yeah you know I you know I
did a couple months in the [ __ ]
Sahara I might be like yeah like wait so
you're saying we went on the moon when
he said something he was like kind of
like a why you seemed so unsure about
this another moon yeah yeah well yeah I
have yeah yeah yeah had a lot of moon
[ __ ] with him too no doubt bro
he gets a lot of because that is the
type of fame that I think moon firm yeah
I mean that's unprecedented you know
when I come back to my place and see the
socks I wore you want to walk in the
shoes I walked in so this past weekend
is brought to you by Skillshare
Skillshare is an online learning
community for creators with more than
2,500 online classes in design business
and more you'll discover count
waste of fuel your creativity your
curiosity and your career that's what's
most important if there's a skill you
want to learn and you want to you you
want to take on a new career you want
that little side piece job style
well now you can learn it without going
to a college course Skillshare take
classes in social media marketing mobile
photography creative writing and even
illustration or drawing whether you want
a new passion a new hustle whatever a
professional skill Skillshare is there
to help join the millions of students
already learning on Skillshare
today with a special offer just for my
listeners get two months of Skillshare
for free that's right Skillshare is
offering this past weekend listeners two
months of unlimited access for over
25,000 classes for free
to sign up go to Skillshare dot-com
slash Theo von
again go to Skillshare dot-com slash
Theo von to start your two months now
that's skill show calm slash Theo von
now back to the show so now would you
say what is the difference between the
famous you had AZ or the popularity you
know that you had as a youtuber or in
that world or and then more as now like
or just what are some of the things that
are different about it YouTube fame is
less people are less respectful like
right it's they assume like you're more
accessible because you know I mean a lot
of youtubers they talk to the camera
yeah and these people feel like they
know them because they're so accessible
they post so often and they don't think
it's always like it's like they think
like they see that guy walking that's
the same guy that they saw in the video
right whereas like an actor they think
oh man that's so-and-so he was
pretending to be you know if he was an
actor in this right so they don't think
they know you I say they just so they're
more like respectful of personal space
if it's from like a show or a movie
whereas if it's YouTube
they didn't just jump on you and put put
their arm around you like take this shot
you're gonna be like I'm gonna take this
shot cuz that's what I do on YouTube and
I'm the same in real life I mean like
I'm gonna [ __ ] stab you [ __ ]
yeah they think that's what I'm walking
around hoping for I guess you know
they're yeah that's how it was for a
while that's how a lot of this hostility
would would to come about because people
would be like take a shot and I'd be
like I do not like that
yeah yeah see the appointment mentally
unsubscribe I just watch it Wow
dude that's a new that that's a great
way to to talk about how people like
yeah they're not disappointed
yeah mentally unsubscribed for me yeah
that's severe what do you think it's
like that would stand up do you think
it's like that would when you do stand
up like people think you're more
accessible um I don't know if comedians
maybe get that a little bit more but I
remember like I think maybe comedians do
a little bit more podcasters do I think
in the podcasting world that's Chris
Farley okay people think it's Trump or
me for a second I thought it was like a
big Trump I could I'm um you know to the
side here but yeah yeah obviously it's
Chris Farley that's dope
yeah pretty cool man thank you um good
good work boy yeah I don't know dude but
but but as being us so now is a
celebrity what's that more like it's a
little bit more or being like a working
in movies in film now yeah I mean it
just when I get recognized for that
stuff it's more of like I mean I would
say just overall lately people have been
a lot more just respectful of national
space just just because like I don't do
the same stuff that I used to I'm not
like so I don't know when people come up
to me now it's usually people are
usually pretty cool they'll just be like
hey man like love what you're doing
right and on my tanks that's cool yeah
you know I have no problem with that
just gonna tell me thank you for doing
what you're doing
yeah they enjoy it yeah yeah
cool but do um what was like somebody
who came up to you're a celeb that hits
you up like like Chris Pratt just
started following me the other day on
Instagram Wright was like a big you know
I Seth Rogen followed me on Twitter if
you really I was like that's that's
awesome and you like responded to one of
my tweets yeah I was cool alright though
mm-hmm that's pretty good not some big
stuff dude yeah it's nothing small I
mean I wish he was a hot chick would be
a lot colder did you have to pay for at
Jimmy no people think I'd probably paid
like a lot of money for at Jimmy but in
reality I had checked on it a while and
what is that Jimmy sorry that's his
Instagram is just Jimmy oh that's dope
yeah so I like checked on it to see like
maybe it's available probably not or
like I wanted to like some guy had it it
was like he had no post and I was like
Yale man could I buy this username and
he never hit me back here like an
inactive account and then my a few
months go by and my friend like said
something in a group chat on Instagram
and he's like at Jimmy you look like
this guy and I was like just clicked at
Jimmy and it said user not found Wow
another way wait wait did I just like
unlock did I just stumble upon this like
it's free now the other guy got
deactivated and I just happened to click
it moment and I just snagged it this
seemed like a see me sit up Broza Simi
Valley that does seem like something
that be on that show we had some
questions here that came from some fans
you let's uh let's hit one of them guys
yeah for sure
Iowa Knicks fan Jimmy was good thanks
penny you too since the YouTube days I
was [ __ ] crying sobbing during birth
drug dealer ever that was one of the
funny
videos man I was wondering if either one
of you guys ever had a real life
experience like that or he's sketchy
times buying some herb back in the day
and another question for you Jimmy
how in the [ __ ] could you get Pauly
Shore in a video back then man that was
had me rollin man Gang Gang piece gang
there you go Jimmy well just directly
enter the Pauly Shore question it was he
was just trying to do YouTube videos at
the time yeah so like I think he had got
in touch with my YouTube network and
like they were trying to set up
collaborations my manager to me I was
like Pauly Shore wants to do YouTube
videos so we wrote something for him
wasn't too wasn't too crazy yeah and
then the drug dealer video that was just
my video called the worst drug dealer
ever
I think I've seen that one before
actually I think I just ended up seeing
that one yeah that was uh I'm just a you
know terrible sketchball that whole time
but I mean I definitely had some kind of
experience like that not probably to
that extent but the drug dealer that
like wants to hang around for way too
long
yeah that's happened yeah yeah oh yeah
that milling around guy yeah the guy who
like wants to then you know smoke the
product with you after he sells it to
you know yeah big smoke game maybe you
should contribute to me yours yeah if
you're gonna be maybe give me the money
I need six dollars back high dude I
remember one time they had um got
stopped over the with a buddy of mine
and he was uh kind of a homoerotic kind
of guy and he was about 44 and he died
actually and I just talked about this
this week on the podcast he died he
drove into an embankment on pills one
time but he and I were Busboys together
and we actually uh and we won he used to
buy weed and I would drive him around
when I was young cuz he was you know
older and had weed and so one time we
get stopped by the police right so the
police take him out of my car and put
him into the car he has a brick of weed
in his shirt right so now
sitting in the cop car with a brick of
weed in his shirt when he's in there he
leaves it in the cop car they ended up
getting him out of the cop car and
letting him go bro so he basically got
escorted to be held detained into a cop
car for a while while they just talked
to me the driver of the vehicle then
they searched the car nothing's on him
because it's nothing's in the car
because it's on him in the cop car then
they decided something happen in there
and or whatever they're gonna let us go
they put him back in my car and he and
he left a weed in the cop car and that
was more like a pound
yeah like whatever you would do that
brick you know that's nuts
[ __ ] Binaca oh wow oh dude and I
thought it was ballsy when my friend
might went to Coachella and kept his
joints in his hand while they patted him
and he just like came up to me he was
like dude and he opened his hand I was
like what where did you have those in my
head just like so easy like oh yeah you
just do one of them you're like which
hand [ __ ] man was it more fun a little
bit when you were do you feel sometimes
like you miss being more unknown because
you could have more fun and more freedom
yeah I think I've I'm definitely like
less outgoing than I used to be like I
think like what before I was like
remotely famous at all I was just like a
lot more open to people I didn't know
right and now like I don't know I just
kind of like the whole College thing it
made me not want to like meet new people
really I'm so like open to like meeting
new people right like I just like
there's now like this hesitancy that I'm
like I I don't if I don't what I'm not
sure about intentions and so I don't
know I hang out with the same friends of
hung out with for the past like 10 years
yeah and like I don't know I it
definitely made me less
outgoing and I'm definitely not down to
like I don't know I just you know you're
certain situations you'd like feel weird
about jumping into you just because
you're like I want to get like
recognized right yeah because if you
could recognize it almost takes it takes
you out of the situation and you can't
be in the situation having fun yeah then
some of the situation becomes about you
which isn't you know and if it's yeah
yeah I really can kind of ruin it it it
can yeah you can yeah you're right it
just like takes you out and all sudden
you're like you're laughing in and all
sending like oh no now I'm noticing that
there's people looking at me yeah now
that you just said that yeah no it's all
kind of ruined yeah now I've got a paper
dinner now I'm just gonna leave yes yeah
that would be a funny way to go about it
getting recognized and just it's just
very visual like you like being very
obvious and it ruins your whole day
alright guys I'm gonna head off wouldn't
that be so become such a great thing if
people knew that you got if somebody
record don't say you [ __ ] know he'll
leave just like that like just laughing
is that becomes your fame mmm oh it's
like [ __ ] you know I can tell you it's
really shook do you are you executive
producing the show that you're on now
yeah I directed it and nobody to was it
scary to think that you could direct
something to first think that you could
and then actually be doing it is that it
was definitely because thinking of
something is one thing sometimes you get
a feeling oh I could do that I could do
that but you finally are doing it it's
like frog like I cuz I mean I've done
sketches on YouTube for so long so it
was like doing it like making something
happen it was like on a small scale like
that was just life but then when it
became like a big thing and like a
facebook show and like you know I'm sure
the set we got trailers and like there's
like a hundred people on the crew that
are there right like I'm answering all
the fine
questions like I learned a lot I
definitely learned a lot and it was
definitely a little overwhelming at
first to be in that situation when it's
like there's no one really to look to
besides like advice you know it's like
all the final decisions are right I have
to make them I have to pull the final
trigger so hey you know a lot of things
that John Wilkes Booth I like that yeah
I mean it was it was fun I mean it was
it was it was awesome
it was great to be able to you know have
you ever been like well let me cha oh
you want to let me check and it's also
like if you're gonna say no to something
that someone else wants it's you can't
really be like yeah they're not gonna
allow that well aren't you the final
well yeah like I oh I don't know if
we're gonna be able to accommodate well
but sure you're not gonna be able to
actually I'm on a texting with my
parents blame stuff on other things so
that kind of makes you have to probably
grow up in some sense is like in a
business sense yeah yeah I mean and I
mean like over the course of the shoot I
just learned I learned so much and like
by the end I was I was coming so much
more prepared and like just from like a
directors standpoint but also from like
an executive producer standpoint because
I mean it is a little weird when you're
like you know I'm like you know 26 and
like all the other producers
besides my buddy who I wrote the show
with are like you know like 40 50 year
old men yeah and like I'm like they're
asking me for like the final answer on
stuff this is it was just a little weird
but I got used to it did it make I don't
plan on getting unused - right right
yeah most of it started to feel like a
sense of pride at some point like you
know not ego but even pride like [ __ ]
this is kind of crazy like I can
actually
do this I mean at the end of this shoot
like when we would finally finished
everything and like everyone's all like
celebrating I was like oh really it was
a really cool moment because I was when
I you know looked around and I was like
this is sick like we did this I did this
yes I did this all these jobs yeah
people are working and people had fun
yeah the DP was like to the job creator
and I was like wow the job creator dilly
dilly
oh and I've never said dilly-dally
before and I would never [ __ ] say it
again either it's cheesy but that
instance felt like it worked it made me
happy
what aha thank you what um woody what do
you feel like his other stuff that you
want to get into now he's certainly
thinking about like give are you doing a
your own production company now yeah
yeah so my production company was did
the shell did the show Valley another
production company but right now what
I'm I'm not sure if I'm allowed to say
like the network but me and Dan Lagaan I
have a medium Agana Funny or Die and CBS
have a development deal for a pilot we
pitched last year that I've been working
on for like three and a half years it's
like loosely about my life kind of the
idea of a guy that famous on YouTube
yeah doesn't really belong in the
YouTube world so it vigilante almost
what vigilante a little bit is yeah
that's how I like to think of myself
yeah you can take your [ __ ] makeup
tutorials and how to hula hoop and your
ASMR and shove it up your ass
forgot about tomorrow yeah did you ever
hook up with any of the ASMR chicks no
[ __ ] bro
how crazy I'm gonna just put like a
really live mic right next your penis
and just had them do the tapping stuff
when your window broke you watch a some
more stuff I mean I haven't seen a lot
of it but I've seen I've seen most of
the food items that they've done yeah
when they started doing furniture and
[ __ ] I was
bring furniture like you know how does
it sound when I tap my hands on a piece
of furniture you know really a little
just dig that yeah I listen to some
antiques but I'm not listening just
[ __ ] [ __ ] from Ikea
you gotta be some quality just learn to
sound expensive yeah I want to hear
something I want to hear a ghost in the
chifforobe you know maybe not even hear
anything
yes tempur-pedic's did you um was there
other businesses and stuff that you
started before you even did YouTube
because you kind of one thing I've
noticed in talking about people that are
like creators and entrepreneurs is that
that that some of that's always been a
spirit of theirs like yeah you know
we're been a practice so there's do you
have like a um you know like a lemonade
stand or even anything like that like
was there something wild you did I
always do you sell a bunch of [ __ ]
shirts like did you do something I it
was always something I wanted to do like
you know definitely a clothing company
who was like one of the ideas what was
it called do you think you had any idea
I think it was called as I had one too
and I can tell you about it I think ours
was called Ltd and it was living the
dream
we were like you bring up living the
dream clothing has that now but clothing
line is like if you're you know a
creative minded individual who doesn't
want to have a nine-to-five job like I
think your first thought is I gotta
start a clothing wearing clothing bro
yeah everybody needs clothing the king
click on one of those men oh there you
go it looks like women's team Ltd yeah
hockey looks like Canadian women's
outdoor wear exactly what we were going
for yeah we had one called Jimmy Blunt
and it was about it was basically just
me and this other kid that smoked weed
in school and we just yeah we had like
all this pictures like this blunt like
on a surfboard and then he was like you
know having a smoothie or you know
that's a way better idea
meeting somebody new or something just
basic things whatever happened nothing
my buddy ended up becoming a cop and I'm
and he got pretty born again and then
unborn and then reborn again he was
[ __ ] just a zygote for Christ by the
end of it all coaster yeah and then yeah
and that was it and the ship fell apart
man
but I had some big ideas I remember uh I
tried to see you around the world one
time I I wrote a letter to see you this
is probably 20 years ago what does she
do see do is like a big roller skate on
the water but it's like a I'm not a
roller skate like a boat but it's just
your boat you know like a jet ski jet
skis okay yeah they used to just call
them sea-doos and I wrote him I was like
I wanna see you around the whole world
and they never wrote him back but it was
you know just weird ideas you know that
I had there's always like big there's
just a couple guys who have left
voicemails who still want to make that
dream happen for you really yeah so we
could we could probably hit them up and
get you around the world while yeah who
were those guys I think first you're
hearing about just couple of guys with
skis jet skis I think but alarming we'll
see but cool could be possible uh yeah I
just noticed that sometimes so II do you
have a so you have a new project with
the same one of the same guys from
America yeah it's like pretty much the
same like vandals scores squad - the
creators of vandal right obviously
that's cool but yeah I'm really excited
about that I've been working on that for
like literally three years I was working
on with someone else it fell through and
now we're gonna them like finally got it
to pitch pitch to last year healing
element deal were you just cast in
vandal or did they did you like come up
with the idea and I kind of help no no I
I didn't I didn't come up with the show
it was just I was just in it do you have
thoughts on season two to give anything
to do a season two oh yeah they do what
season two but I really like season two
yeah I don't know if you yeah I thought
it was really good yeah I thought it was
brave amounts of diarrhea in it I was
like oh there's not gonna be still more
diarrhea yeah it's all really on there
like the guy did all out
yeah but it resonated that the second
episode still felt you know it burned a
little let's take another question that
came in you know you got the most calls
that have ever come in for a guest that
we've had really and we've had some
honestly guests that I thought were
better than you just have a similar demo
yeah no we're very happy to have you
here here's another one is to pay
tribute ater what's going on
I just wondering mr. Tatro when is the
next balcony conversations gang gang
gang gang gang when's that next balcony
conversations what is it it's it's a
series I do with my buddy Christian
where we just are on the balcony and
just have conversations like the lowest
production YouTube video that we can do
that people still really enjoy right and
we just talk about like different topics
and stuff but the next one I'm not sure
probably in the next couple months it's
like anytime we like want to talk about
something instead of like it's almost
like a podcast kind of you know it's
like if we just wrote a conversation for
us to have right just had it on a
balcony yeah do you think um and that
guy also seemed like that from Clockwork
Orange didn't mean a little bit I've
ever seen that movie I haven't seen it
no it was like a scary movie when I was
young I know I'll constantly disappoint
you at any movie that you want to
reference mm-hmm I probably haven't seen
it damn that's pretty cool let's take it
let's do it other one speaking o'clock
one question for Jimmy Pedro what have
you done to make the world a better
place I know you're Vaughn's been
preaching what have you been doing here
like dengue like that guy has come on
him somewhere what have you been doing
to make what are you gonna make a world
a better place and he says Theo just
preaches
yeah yeah I mean I basically am just
doing not much so what are you doing I
just you know I think making people
laugh there you go I think that's making
the world a better place
yeah bringing something a little joy you
could be doing crime too okay if you did
crime what would it be man and be honest
like if I was gonna be like a bad guy
yeah I mean you're doing a crime brother
somebody's gonna die someone's gonna die
yeah we're not doing way too excited
about I don't want that you [ __ ] you
know oh whoa we're gonna get right back
to this question if there's a a video
question came in and these people look
semi-nude so let's hear this one and and
very related to the crime thing
so it's the
he said he got out of jail yeah he said
he's got a tidge ls9 he's laying in bed
with the young lady who was of age I
will say that I've been to jail have you
been to jail I've been in jail
yeah I've been twice I know I know that
I've been once drunk yep one time I was
drunk and high and they found a kid
upstairs in this house and they said it
was somebody's kid and we're all like
that ain't our kid and then we all went
to jail you know yeah you can't get all
[ __ ] up in a house with as a kid
sleeping upstairs who is the kid that's
why I that you know the defense rests
brother that was my question
and then people thought that they were
taking Islita kid around and putting him
in places and you know like the cops
were just busting people like that oh
wow but where was that this was in
Mississippi mmm in Natchez Mississippi
so both the time zone with Jill were in
Arizona oh wow so I'm not a big fan of
Arizona and do they give you extra water
on the job there cuz yeah I feel I could
get so dehydrated in jail there I know
No would you go for I went both times
the second time let me both times were
[ __ ] ridiculous the first time I was
just really drunk and like I was
I like blacked in mm-hmm when cop lights
were coming down the street and I was
walking down the street an elf costume
with my other friend yeah three
originally so I'm like all of a sudden
my friend takes off you gotta understand
like I just landed I just got there yeah
I don't even know where I rank for the
past two hours
so elf one takes off and my icy cop
lights and I'm like wait wait wait why
are you running are we doing something
wrong I just got here I have no context
so I just start running and I jump a
fence and I land on the other side of
the fence and I just hear freeze and
they made me come back over the fence
which I did which I the [ __ ] back
over the fence where I was this fat is
fat ass cops not gonna jump this spike
was like a 10-foot spiky fence that I
somehow jumped like a ninja and now I'm
climbing back over the fence and I give
the guy a my like
I D he finds my fake ID and they
basically just brought me to jail for
being drunk underage damn and I was in
an elf costume the whole time [ __ ] the
second time they raided our house
because they thought we were drug
dealers which we weren't and then they
brought me outside of the house after
they they slammed my face into the
ground so that we hope we're getting
bangs on the door there's like ten
people at her house it's like a very
like we're smoking weed it's like a leap
wow they do that were you in blackface
oh yeah understand at least then they
would at least anyone had a reason to do
it you know what I was a bad for God no
it was like they thought we were drug
dealers I was getting like a lot of
packages uh-huh yeah clothing company
yeah [ __ ] we had like I had my drug
dealer looking challenger in the job
yeah there's always weed coming out of
our house so like they thought we were
drugs it rolled the whole Western
coordinate of Tucson police helicopters
dogs they run in guns drawn
hacklin said I was preventing them from
getting to the couch because there was a
girl on the couch waiting for an uber
with my friend who she had just hooked
up with and they said he was holding her
down and I was preventing him from
getting her [ __ ] which was nuts they
slam my face boom boom I'm bleeding like
what the [ __ ] they kicked down doors
wake everyone up and mouth didn't find
anything they're like all right place is
clear red tag the house give all the
minors at my peas and let's get out of
here damn and I'm like that's [ __ ] they
bring me outside breathalyze me I blow
up point 1 1 which is 0.03 over the
legal and she's nothing they bring me to
jail you're any driving for being drunk
underage after they pulled me out of my
house because they didn't have anything
they were like I'll [ __ ] we [ __ ] up
let's bring this kid to jail honestly we
could have sued the [ __ ] I am brother
Smurf he's lost but I didn't have I
didn't it was like 500 bucks to sit down
with a lawyer I didn't have that kind of
money [ __ ] yeah it was messed up and I
was like I was in the back of the cop
car like they didn't even let me bring
my shirt or like my wallet or my phone
a nail yeah I'm like sitting in the back
of the cop car cuffed and this guy is
driving me and I could see in his eyes
he knew it was [ __ ] up yeah and I'm
sitting there I'm like just why you got
into this job man
it's just why you do this I was like you
know this is [ __ ] up and he's like
dude I don't know what to say man I'm
like this is so [ __ ] I was I was like
really good you know what the [ __ ]
sound yeah but then I got out of jail
like 8:00 a.m. I don't have a phone I
don't have a wallet saw and I'm like
walking around freeing a little bit was
it relaxing no I like vegan like that
but not when I'm getting out of jail
yeah and you're trying to ask someone in
the parking lot to borrow your phone get
away from me jail guy yeah you know yeah
where have you been it's just says jail
behind you yeah I'm like hey know where
we are but like you have a phone I could
borrow no one wanted to let me borrow
their phone so I just started walking
and turns out we were nine miles away
from campus hmm and I walked all the way
there because I just didn't want to like
I didn't know what to do I just started
walking in the direction yeah oh yeah
and I [ __ ] get home at like 11:00
a.m. like I had taken my Jail [ __ ] off
people are driving by recognizing me
like walk of [ __ ] no idea where I've
been damn yeah it was a really gnarly 24
hours [ __ ] but that's real you got in
the system man you could but that's such
that's a lot of system action you know
you didn't have the money to get that
attorneys you like just [ __ ] now you're
back on the street you're [ __ ] angry
yeah I know got a chip on my shoulder
yeah and anything can happen yeah I like
that how about you what was your Jail
what happening just that one time they
took the kids in you know they said you
guys are [ __ ] man and uh whose kid is
this they brought a kid down from
upstairs and everybody was like it was a
kid in there imagine being in a house
for a long time having a great time
suddenly a kid comes downstairs that
nobody knows right yeah yeah it's like
the shining bro and I was like well I
don't know that kid and like you're
[ __ ] going to jail and the kid they
they ask the kid I remember point out
the people you know in the room in the
kid went like this and went to each
person just
no way anyone there yeah there's like 80
sounds like a shut up
oh dude that's also like smells like a
setup look at that [ __ ] kid man you
know that's good is that and that's it
man and they took us and I was pretty I
guess it wasn't an unenjoyable but it
was interesting how long were you in
just for the night in the in the big
house yeah just me and this the biggest
guy ever he literally took up 11% of the
cell right and I took up 3% of the cell
bro
but it was just I felt like he [ __ ]
was getting more than I was I knew I had
an issue but it was a good you know it
was what it was man housing cellmates is
alarming yeah I had to did you and
they're both covered head-to-toe tattoos
it was the first time when I was in an
elf costume yeah Oh in year if there's a
let's play somebody's getting [ __ ] in
here yeah I was wearing tights it's you
yeah so I knew I made good shape what
were you in good shape I was in good
shape but I was still concerned you know
I woke up in an elf costume with tights
on I don't know I don't know where I am
I just all I see is two guys with face
tattoos oh yeah staring at me one dudes
like it's in his neck like fully meth
doubt time to [ __ ] grant wait and I
brought it up and I've probably told
this story like a hundred times but I
literally stood up in the first thing I
said was Shannon's gonna be so pissed
and then these guys love me they're like
oh this guy I like walking into a
holding area the next morning and like
everyone here everyone like snickering
and like 19 each other like yo elf man's
back he's back and I'm like apparently
like I was causing a scene the night
before yeah I wasn't even aware of tan
that [ __ ] dirty off the strippers
back that's the worst
do they like elf man's back you know
that's concerning yeah why am i back the
strippers back what happened dude we
used to have this thing called foot
gypping and I've talked about this one
girls would he put a hit of acid in
their vaginas right when I was growing
up and then one night we got all you
know everybody got keyed up on some dope
and somebody went on
and they had to somebody made love to a
woman and then they wanted to get up
there like she wouldn't take a plan b
pill you know because he thought maybe
they were gonna start a family on
accident and he's like dude we got a
sneak back over to her place and while
she's sleeping we got to put this plan b
pill in her
yeah I'm like dude I think death does
take it orally yeah you know and oral is
somewhere else and yeah I don't think
that that's how it works don't think you
should slip ahead of Plan B into
somebody you know they don't make a
suppository you know what I'm saying
and then the baby's just going back to
heaven you know that's crazy I thought
you were gonna say put it in her drink
or something like a like a normal deal
nah I wish I would've man but that's
look a lot of people a bad ideas
thankfully that I got that guy's idea
didn't pan out let's take out two more
calls here for uh mister Tatro
I have a question for Jimmy and it is
how old are you
when when your boys often got to low
sultry voice right well Gang Gang really
yeah yeah it must had a hog on you at 12
huh oh my god it was not this low you
could have been a police officer I'm
still low yeah the people I asked you to
buy them liquor we use a girl like the
guy and your friends I would go in and
try to use a fake ID
well no cuz I never looked that young I
mean I never looked that old I was like
I didn't have all I didn't have facial
hair really so it was like like facial
hair was a big yeah a big component to
who is getting the liquor yeah that's a
good point God wanted you that had a
beard literally at 11 years old this you
had a [ __ ] beard and he prided
himself on it I mean that's big oh dude
and he [ __ ] all he cared about he was
silk that [ __ ] up you have more face
rather than his fat than his father
and he [ __ ] loved that [ __ ] and he
would buy liquor he would buy probably
$2,000 worth of alcohol in the weekend I
can't believe that people didn't be like
what do you do you look like Abraham
Lincoln all the and he really he almost
dressed like him to a little bit he
started to kind of live the the vibe
hmm what was that guy's question how old
was I when my voice dropped oh yeah mm
um do you have a is there a like a kind
of a crazy movie or something you were
almost in that we don't know about real
most Aquaman or something I could see
being a murderer I would like to be
something like that bro you could
[ __ ] murder somebody dude in a movie
yeah I would well I would love to play
like a crazy you know me like a killer
yeah I'm talking about I could see
somebody just hiding under the [ __ ]
floorboards listening to somebody sleep
for a month I'm saying I'm talking dark
heart bro yeah you could do it I think
you could do it man
d we're
you noticed as your careers progress
that you've started to have bigger
dreams almost and bigger ambitions has
that been something that's something I
noticed sometimes like [ __ ] I hope I'll
one day I'll be able to do this and then
once you're doing that you're like well
[ __ ] maybe I could do this yeah yeah I
mean I'm still I'm still like like I
would like to have you know a production
company that like I can just kind of do
whatever I want with and make I mean I
just want to be able to creatively do
whatever I want to do yes that's just
the goal and I'm like I'm at a point
where like I've been able to do like the
show was like creatively it's like a lot
of freedom I just want to keep doing
things like that and hopefully hopefully
get a version of what I had on my
youtube channel and a much larger scale
yeah well it's more of like a like a
mini studio almost where we can just
pump out like movies or shows or
whatever I want to make what are the
goal what are some of your strongest
skills do you notice for yourself like
have you III think I'm I'm good at its
like understanding like where other
people are coming from and situations I
guess like I don't know I'm that wasn't
a good way to phrase what I was trying
to say at all right but a story in my
life yeah I don't know I mean I think
like even as an entertainer kind of or
yeah or as a cuz I start to notice like
oh as I get a little bit older I start
to notice you know oh these are skills
and I'm actually having [ __ ] some of
these skills I thought I have I do not
have you know yeah it might be kind of a
vague question um let's take another one
question I gotta work on it I got to
work on a better answer to that question
yeah I think I'm I noticed that I need
more help from people then I realized a
lot of times I don't like to give I like
to be more controlling even though the
that I can't do things all by myself so
it's like kind of like you know just
recognizing that you know my opinion
isn't always the best one in the room
even though like there's something in my
head that wants to tell me that it is
you know um I'm a better creator than I
am a organizer like I'm more crew only
creative facade and I shouldn't have a
dog right now there's a lot of mature
realizations that you got there some of
those dude I mean I'm [ __ ] bro you
know I can't do cocaine right now so
that's that
let's take me Colin in for for Jimmy I
just had a question on how he linked up
with some all those guys from root boys
of sinners Valley that cover Rico and it
can get it because I know that they were
on time for a number to Nepean on there
and I've got to watch all those guys for
a while so the dudes from real broads
you see no Natalie
Duncan who plays Duncan Duncan is a guy
named nick colletti okay they're a
Griffin on the show the total of Simi
Valley bronies a good name it's Griffin
Xander Duncan and Wade no not greater
than sorry it's Xander Wade Duncan and
Bryce those are the four members
four-eyes yeah and then and then like
and then you meet another group of bros
yonder oh yeah I can't with the name
yonder at lunch one time and I was like
so good squad is its yonder any like the
guys like yonder that's your name and
he's like yeah yonder like yo yonder
that's a pixel will be one next pixel
seems like a girl that's a good one day
I love great fictional names yeah we got
a we we added a genre and to John Erwin
no John oh yeah John is good Johnny
Johnny
piss johansson is a good name I love
like like a good full name that's what I
think they did so well on vandal was
these fictional names like Declan Man
Escala hat Nick away
Duncan Fairchild all these fake names I
don't know how you guys come up with
these but they're brilliant yeah but the
dudes on real bros I knew through a
couple of them I had heard of from vine
vine yeah yeah yeah Chris D'Elia is a
friend of mine he's a big vine star I
don't know if he does I mean I think he
might now but he's I mean he any medium
he takes on he's a conqueror you know
yeah I just I I cuz I started to hate it
when I like I started making vines just
like for fun yeah before people started
editing on them [ __ ] yeah and then
people start telling me to be like yo
you're that guy from vine and I was like
oh no I don't like that no it's a grape
yeah but these guys I had heard of from
vine and they were like I mean I thought
the vine got to the point where like I
hated like everything on vine yeah but I
thought I always thought these guys were
funny and the two dudes on it were the
guys who did like those started those
videos so excited sorry
yeah that's pretty much yeah quick easy
but uh we'd had them do another video so
I met him like through that and then the
other guy Cody I'd had do like a I used
to do a drunk questions which is kind of
like what we're doing now except like
drinking right and then posting it on
YouTube oh yeah
which you know so brave though yeah I'd
post it and I'd be like oh that's way
too much info yeah oh definitely dude I
mean I'm crying and half of the videos
that we have up but it is interesting
that it's like yay there's so much more
freedom when you're first starting out
and then it starts to not the freedom
but it everything it does start to
change a little bit like with Twitter
like I used to be down to tweet whatever
oh yeah
I'd be like all [ __ ] that's a funny
thought yeah I don't care help yeah and
now it's like well there's a lot of
people that are gonna see this so maybe
I shouldn't say that maybe it could be
perceived the wrong way yeah and also
that Twitter's become a place where
people go to find a quote that just
matches anything that they want to prove
so it's like oh yeah you know dragon
Hickey 9 got so pissed at uh you know at
Trump or at Hillary and you're like who
gives a [ __ ] who that person is no it's
just like it's just a place they can go
to almost find anything they want yeah
you know yeah it's [ __ ] concerning
dude I'm hoping the aliens come and
they're down [ __ ] you know what's crazy
about aliens coming is I fully
experienced an alien invasion like yeah
in hindsight I'm aware that it wasn't an
alien invasion okay what'd it sound like
it at the time hmm I was I experienced
the feelings
remember when SpaceX launched that
rocket I had no idea that was happening
yeah and all of a sudden we see all
these people outside we're in Starbucks
oh my god oh my god like the sounds of
like what it sounds like in movies when
an alien dates yeah we go outside
everyone's filming the sky and there's
this massive like colorful cloud and
these these two things that are just my
friend kept saying these plumes of
plasma freaking out like oh my god it's
happening
we're running we're like filming this
thing and like another thing sprouts
from it it was like there was a lot
going on in the sky did y'all think it
was the Lord he thought it was all sorry
I thought it was a full-on like I
thought it was arrivals like the movie I
thought that was happening and and you
know a guy was like you got to see the
video I took and he's video was crazier
I'm like [ __ ] your video and it's still
in the sky yeah I'm like you got us you
got to send me that yeah I'm thinking
like I'm gonna be sending this to CNN
it's gonna be a huge deal that aliens
are invading and I thought like wow and
obviously now you know makes
she was spacex oh [ __ ] people got an
accident on the freeway that's what this
video is showing as it went but that is
a weird thing in the sky and in that
that light started expanding yeah you
can see it right there it looks almost
like a coffin or something shaped and my
honest thought was I thought that that
itself might have been the alien
I thought the alien might have been
coming in cloud form or something right
I was freaking out some new thing that
we can't hand this yeah we don't know
and what was your plan how what was your
next move gonna I don't know we were
running towards it I was like I was
interested I just wanted to like I don't
know but did you start thinking like oh
do I have a sword do I have like my
phone charged like to give any I was
just my mind was just racing I just
don't even know I wasn't thinking of
solutions I was just I think it was just
pure interest in yeah what is this it's
an alien for sure yeah we gotta check
this out and you know it was crazy
because like I said like I feel like I
like I had the real feelings that I
would have felt oh wow yeah you got all
that natural reactions like I had the
feeling of oh [ __ ] this is in it's
happening this is what I'm wearing we're
both it's happening dude I can't believe
this yeah and now is you know did it
have the feeling that so so if you get
that that feeling when the aliens come
was it the kind of thing you were cool
it was fun to be with your boys for it
would have been something cool for me to
be with like a chick like on a date I
was I don't know I was I was like my
best friend so it seemed like a pretty
it was a good situation yeah I mean I
just I don't know like I said I wasn't
like I wasn't thinking like what was my
plan right it was just [ __ ] it was just
more of a I was in awe that it it was
happening like we did it did you feel
like that I don't know I was I was just
I was like I huh are they I thought they
were like firing yeah look it was a
rocket you know and stuff was shooting
off of it and the ulong's really got to
do a better job of telling us that
that's happening yes something he should
definitely uh spruce it up a little bit
yeah cars are crashing on the freeway
dude whew you
you know it's just different times man
I'm ready for an alien I'm ready for the
Lord I'm ready for [ __ ] quicksand
brother quicksand
I'll do whatever I thought quicksand was
gonna be a much much more what's the
word prevalent problem yeah ya do ya I
thought twins we're gonna be everywhere
when I was young prince oh dude yeah one
summer they had two sets of twins and
moved to our town and I was like oh my
[ __ ] god
dude there's gonna be so many [ __ ]
extra people in the future I thought if
so many more twins were like being in
the world and my whole concept was just
like [ __ ] did you have any quicksand
where you were me were you from there
from the southern Louisiana yeah I'm
from Louisiana and they had we had a lot
of sinkholes growing up you know I grew
up in the sinkhole Belt
I guess whatever that is basically a
ravine but they used to test kids you
could get a job do five bucks an hour
they hooked this thing on you and hook a
thing you'd walk out into a field and
see if you'd [ __ ] fall in and they
need to be out there all day working
with like a um not landscapers really
called the government's landscapers like
Caltrans or no that's not cow friends um
I don't know but yeah something we don't
know but uh he'd walk out in the field
and be like [ __ ] walk a little more
you know we're splitting the beer he
walk we got you and that yet they tie
you off and if like [ __ ] walk in a
big circle man see if you [ __ ] hit
anything
you were like Donnie you were like kind
of like a metal detector but the metal
was falling into the earth you know
right and so if you hit a sinkhole when
you [ __ ] went down you know like all
right you know yeah well we're gonna
need some sod you know so that was it
man that was kind of like a fun thing
you could do when I was growing up
that's quick sandy yeah it's kind of
quick sandy but that's the most ever saw
but yeah I thought was gonna be a lot
bigger they had a do bus you tried to
make it I remember for a while and sell
it to people
quick said yeah like your own quicksand
yeah he couldn't do it the quicksand box
and he couldn't do it didn't they shut
him down
are your kids bored with their normal
sand casts the quicksand box
settle men never seemed like yeah
where's Lawrence who knows and it's like
it almost it just keeps coming back up
kind of regurgitating oh there's a
hassle any other good questions we're
good I think we're good
okay so we need to check out your new
show for the people that haven't seen it
mm-hmm yeah real Bros of Simi Valley yes
Facebook watch and yeah and I was so
down I got a two that we're trying to
make well I have a show with Dan lagana
two that we're trying to look yeah we're
the best [ __ ] man win don't you just
tried to get information out of here
that's why we brought you yeah dammit
it's just about you know it's about a
young fella down on his luck you know
just basically looking for an edge man
looking to get ahead you know and he's
got uh you know he might he might have
done some different you know some poor
ideas and this and that so pretty vague
people way more vague and it's obviously
a developed idea you know what I well
that's what Dan McGann is for Oh a vague
off huh I know you want to have a baby
well I was somewhere my show is based on
something to do with me yeah it happened
[Music]
I'm actually meeting up with we're gonna
after this on FaceTime
right now I'm texting you
well dude thanks for all the
entertainment and all the humor man did
thanks for thanks for having me this has
been a good time you know a lot of time
to go on podcast and yeah I leave
feeling like I said way too much yeah
but I think I think you know I didn't I
think I said too much
oh no no one's I think I said enough
yeah I mean I only think he dug yourself
a hole you might have dug yourself some
quicksand yeah they're pretty gay ending
but no not that we've said could be
worse than Jionni's [ __ ] laugh that
is from me 1500s from 1500 Europe from
the Titanic um that's it man that's all
I got amen
it's a good time dude thanks for coming
and hanging out yeah man it was great to
meet you yeah you're so funny bro and
thank you for uh for stopping in and you
know we'll definitely check out the show
yeah tell everybody to check it out a
lot of creepy [ __ ] dudes listen to
this podcast yeah yeah and I'm sure they
got time to kill people and people and
I'm one of those creepy dudes so Jimmy's
hetero thank you so much man thanks man
[Music]
but when I reach that round I'll share
this piece of my my I can feel it enough
thought it's gonna take
a little time for me to set that parking
brake
Oh
[Music]